>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C..
>> Ladies and Gentlemen.
A video message from
the fourteenth Librarian
of Congress, Carla Hayden.
>> Dr. Carla Hayden: Good
evening, and thank you
for joining the Library
on this special night.
Remembering Denis Johnson,
recipient of the 2017
Prize for American Fiction.
I'm sorry I can't
be there with you.
But I know it will be a
memorable conversation
with these extraordinary
authors.
The Library of Congress honors
a writer's lifetime achievement.
The Fiction Prize,
at the National Book
Festival each year.
So I didn't want to miss
the opportunity to share
with you some news
about this year's event.
On Saturday, September 1.
Once again, this
celebration of books
and reading will feature some
of the biggest names
in every genre.
In History, I'm thrilled to
announce that former Secretary
of State, Madeleine
Albright, will join us.
Also Doris Kearns Goodwin, John
Meacham, and Ron [inaudible].
Best-selling author Amy Tan
will discuss her new memoir.
Where the Past Begins.
Dave Eggers, Jennifer Egan,
and Isobel Liende
will all be with us.
And children's author
and Pulitzer Prize winner
Junot Diaz will join us.
Our US Poet Laureate Tracy K.
Smith, and National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature,
Jacqueline Woodson
will be there too.
This is just a hint
at the things to come.
More names will be
announced soon.
I hope to see you there.
>> Please welcome the
Director of National
and International
Outreach, Dr. Jane McAuliffe.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Jane McAuliffe:
Good evening.
As you've just heard, I'm
Jane McAuliffe, the Director
of National and International
Outreach here at the Library.
On behalf of all of my
colleagues, it's a pleasure
to welcome you to Stories
from a Fallen World.
The Library of Congress' Prize
for American Fiction
Tribute to Denis Johnson.
Tonight is the third in what
has become an annual celebration
of the prize and its winners.
And I know that we all
find pleasure in the fact
that in today's hectic world.
We can pause and take an
evening to recognize the power
of literature to
change our perceptions.
Along with our Poet Laureate,
the prize for American
Fiction stands
as the Library's highest
honor to an American writer.
It seeks to commend strong,
unique, enduring voices
who have told us something new
about the American experience.
Denis Johnson certainly
deserves the honor.
As last year's prize winner,
Marilynne Robinson
has said about him.
"I have never known a writer who
was so identical with his work.
Whose thoughts and passions
and energies were so entirely
of one substance with the
world he remade as fiction."
The great energy of his
imagination was a fusion
of honesty and seriousness.
Pain and laughter.
His life was a thing of
the moment and urgency,
pure and undistracted.
Denis left us too soon, but
we have an amazing group
of his writing peers,
literary and journalistic.
Here with us tonight to help
celebrate his life and work.
It should be a fascinating
discussion that reflects
in strikingly different
ways the gritty themes
that course through his stories.
Before we get started, I'd like
to recognize Cindy Johnson,
Denis' widow, and his
daughter, Lana Burke.
We're so very glad that you
could join us this evening.
I'd also like to recognize Avida
Basharad [assumed spelling],
Deputy Publisher
of Random House.
Random House is the proud
publisher of Denis' work.
Now please let me welcome
my colleague John Haskell
to the stage.
To tell you just a bit about
one of our hosts this evening.
The John W. Kluge Center
here at the Library.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Haskell:
Thank you, Jane.
And thank you all for coming.
The Kluge Center's proud to
be co-sponsor of this event.
It's a continuation of a
collaboration we've had
with the Poetry and
Literature Center.
To celebrate the winners in
the Prize for American Fiction.
The tribute to this particular
literary giant fits perfectly
into the Kluge Center's mission.
Which is to be a
bridge between scholars
and writers on the one hand.
And policy makers and the
interested public on the other.
And that's to foster a
continuing conversation
of the challenges
facing democracies
in the twenty-first century.
Before we get to the program, I
want to give a quick shout-out
to the National Endowment
to the Humanities.
Who's gotten the word out to, to
a lot of you about this event.
And also to thank them
for the work they do
in collaboration
with the Library.
Right now we have a brief
video featuring Denis Johnson.
>> "English words
are like prisms.
Empty, nothing inside.
And still they make rainbows."
So says a character
in Already Dead.
A novel by the late, great
American writer, Denis Johnson.
Johnson's stories, as
legions of his fans know.
Are also prisms.
They are hard, merciless,
flinty,
and yet they too make rainbows.
He's been called a
writer's writer's writer.
And for all the enigma
of that string of words,
they hold a simple truth.
Those who bring language
to life recognize Johnson's
gifts instantly.
Louise Erdrich calls his work
"profound" and "transcendent."
Jonathan Franzen finds
his sentences "miracles
of transparency and tone."
Philip Roth calls him "daring,
terrifying, and an emissary
for tortured, broken souls."
Marilynne Robinson marvels that
a writer's personal passions
and energies can be
so inextricably wedded
to his words.
All agree Denis Johnson has
managed to give us minimalist
yet distinctly ecstatic and
hallucinatory rainbow prose.
He is an American original.
He was born in 1949
in Munich, Germany.
And raised in Tokyo and Manila,
the child of American diplomats.
As a teenager, moving
back to Washington,
D.C. during the tumultuous
sixties,
he came to know the country
and the restless characters.
He would capture so
vividly in his fiction.
He graduated in English
Literature
from the University of Iowa.
And earned an MFA from
the Iowa Writers' Workshop
where he returned as a teacher.
He has also taught at
Texas State University.
And the University
of Texas at Austin.
In the course of his fevered
career, he published novels,
short stories, journalism,
and poetry.
Among his best-known works
are those about the flotsam
and jetsam of American life.
The Laughing Monsters.
Nobody Move.
Tree of Smoke.
Already Dead.
Jesus' Son.
Resuscitation of a Hanged
Man, The Stars at Noon.
Fiskadoro.
Angels. He's received
numerous award for these,
including a National Book award,
a Lannan Fellowship in Fiction,
a Whiting Writers' Award, and
in 2008 he was named a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize.
Throughout, he had
chronicled an America
that has gone unobserved,
unrecorded.
Here are our drug addicts, our
war veterans, our disaffected.
Our used up and left behind.
And yet the most affecting
and rewarding aspect
of Denis Johnson's fiction.
Is that in work after
work he has proved
that beauty often lurks
in unexpected places.
That strength can
be found in failure.
That the human spirit is a
fragile but resilient vessel.
His is a very American story.
He once described his works as
pressure cookers of language.
His characters as those who
inhabit life's perilous edge.
As time wore on, he found
that he himself was
all too vulnerable
to these human frailties.
When the Librarian of
Congress, Carla Hayden,
offered Denis Johnson the
Library of Congress Prize
for American Fiction
in March of 2017.
He wrote in an email
message, "My head is spinning
from such great news."
Two months later,
tragically, he was dead.
The Library is very proud
to honor posthumously this
extraordinary human being
and writer whose contributions
to the American canon have
been lasting and invaluable.
As the Librarian wrote when
the prize was announced
in June 2017, "Denis Johnson
was a writer for our times.
In prose that fused
grace with grit.
He spun tale after tale
about our walking wounded,
the demons that haunt,
the salvation we seek.
We emerge from his imagined
world with profound empathy,
a different perspective,
a little changed."
We are very proud to count Denis
Johnson among the distinguished
winners of the Library
of Congress Prize
for American Fiction.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Arana: Good
evening, Ladies and Gentlemen.
My name is Marie Arana.
And I have the privilege
of serving as the Literary
of Congress and to the Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
One of my most rewarding
responsibilities is directing
the jury that governs
this distinguished award.
The Library of Congress
Prize for American Fiction.
In that capacity, I get to
work with wonderful scholars
like the ones you've just heard.
Jane McAuliffe, and John
Haskell, as well as the head
of the Poetry and
Literature Center,
Rob Casper whom you'll meet
at the end of the program.
Every year a jury of 27
distinguished literary critics,
Nobel Laureates in Literature,
Man Booker Award winners.
Former winners of this prize put
forward three American authors
they think most deserving.
The Librarian of Congress
makes the final selection.
The purpose of that
award is spelled
out on the back of
your programs.
Is to commend strong,
unique, enduring voices.
That throughout long,
consistently accomplished
careers,
have told us something new
about the American experience.
Past awardees have been
Herman Wouk, Philip Roth,
Isabel Allende, Don DeLillo,
E.L. Doctorow, Louise Erdrich,
John Grisham, Marilynne
Robinson, and Toni Morrison.
The choice of our tenth
prize winner, Denis Johnson,
made by Dr. Hayden in
March of last year.
And then confirmed in a
prize ceremony in September.
Was especially thrilling for
me, as I've been a dedicated fan
of Denis' work since I
stumbled onto Resuscitation
of a Hanged Man, back
in the early nineties.
When I was a little
younger than I am now.
And found myself bowled
over by his language,
its emotional force.
Its precision.
As one reviewer wrote, quote,
"His novels like poems seem
to be written line to line."
Unquote. But the full power
of his stories transcends even
his considerable prose mastery.
Denis' stories land
like a swift punch,
somewhere between gut and heart.
The last time I spoke to
Denis, it was on the phone.
Trying to persuade him
to be here tonight.
He had been so delighted by
Dr. Hayden's call and the news
that he was the chosen honorees.
I exchanged emails with
him just after that call.
But he was also an
immensely private man.
He didn't like public
expressions of admiration.
Indeed he had been
conveniently away
in some war zone
reporting a story
when the National Book
Award was conferred
on his ten years before.
For his devastatingly
powerful work, Tree of Smoke.
I tried valiantly
to argue my case
that he should join us here.
That he didn't need to do much.
Just come, sit out there in
the audience with all of you
and be lauded and celebrated.
And given his due for being one
of the great American
literary figures of our time.
He was polite.
He was friendly.
He let me talk and talk.
[Laughter] That phone call
which lasted a good long
while, as I remember.
And during which I felt
with every passing minute
that my powers of
persuasion were failing me.
Ended with, "Umm,
I don't think so."
[Laughter] He just couldn't
bring himself to do it.
That was on May 18, 2017.
Six days later, he was gone.
Now we're here, gathering
to honor him in his absence.
Thinking about how best
to celebrate Denis.
We decided that might please him
most, given his gimlet-eyed view
of public expressions
of admiration.
Might be to turn our lights
in the other direction.
We decided to pay tribute to him
by honoring others in his name.
Choosing three exemplary
American writers whose works
reflect in one way or
another the themes that are
so present in Denis' work.
They would be excellent writers
at the top of their form.
Very different practitioners
of the craft.
Three greats who, like
Denis, tell stories,
fiction or nonfiction.
Excuse me.
Stories of a Fallen World.
The human costs of
addiction, for instance.
The terrible fog of war.
The essential alienation
and disconnectedness
that define modern-day America.
If we do this right, tonight
you'll see a little bit
of Denis and his obsessions.
In all three of these
brilliant wordsmiths.
I'd like to tell you
something about each.
Right up front, right
here before we sit down.
In reverse order of
their appearance.
So that when I actually
bring them on,
the last shall be the first.
Let me start in that
spirit with someone
who will actually
follow the writers.
She is Elizabeth Cuthrell, a
very accomplished film producer
who wrote and produced the
film version of Jesus' Son
that stark, searing, often
funny, quirkily funny collection
of stories for which Denis
is probably best known.
Elizabeth is co-founder
of Evenstar Films.
An independent film and
theater production company.
She's turned out numerous
prize-winning movies as well
as acclaimed theater
productions on both coasts.
She also produced a
stunning series of,
of public service announcements.
Called Stop the Hate.
You're urging racial tolerance,
for which she won
the Courage Award.
We're especially thankful, very
grateful to Elizabeth for coming
to share with us her long-time
friendship with Denis Johnson.
Sam Quinones is the author of
Dreamland, a true masterpiece
of journalism about
the opioid crisis
and the widespread addiction
that has ravaged small town
America and the heartland.
His book is powerful, absorbing,
urgent, a monumental achievement
that drills down on the harsh
realities that Denis described
so memorably in fiction.
The winner of the National
Book Critics' Circle Award,
a finalist for the
L.A. Times Book Prize.
And named one of the
best books of 2015,
it's a book every
American should read.
A book that tracks a
spiraling drug trade.
A voracious, unfettered
pharmaceutical industry.
And hundreds of thousands of
lives strewn along the way.
We're very lucky to have
Sam with us tonight.
Elliott Ackerman, a United
States Marine served five tours
of duty in Iraq.
And Afghanistan, and is the
recipient of the Silver Star,
the Bronze Star for valor,
and the Purple Heart.
His essays and short stories
have appeared in the New Yorker,
the Atlantic, the New
Republic, among many others.
His first book, Green on
Blue, is a harrowing, brutal,
utterly absorbing novel about
an Afghan orphan trapped
in the savage fog of war.
Elliot's second novel,
Dark at the Crossing,
published just last year.
Is about a young
Arab American caught
in the Syrian conflagration.
The novel was a finalist
for the National Book Award.
And named one of the
best books of 2017.
He'll publish a new novel this
fall called Waiting for Eden
about an American
veteran home from the war.
Drastically damaged in
mind, spirit, and body.
Elliot, it's great
to have you here.
Jonathan Franzen, our
first guest tonight,
is renowned for plumbing
the depths
of the modern American psyche.
He is a past master of the
essential loneliness and anxiety
that permeates contemporary
life.
And the wild, careening twists
of fate that can throw it all
out of whack, and
send it spinning.
Jon's talent for forming
striking narratives
out of ordinary life is
abundantly evident in his work.
Most recently in his richly
imagined novel, Purity.
Which has been called
his most fleet-footed,
intimate novel yet.
"If some authors are
masters of suspense,
others post-modern
verbal acrobats,"
Publisher's Weekly wrote.
"And still others complex
character pointillists,
few excel in all three arenas."
Jon is the authors
of four other novels.
Among them, Freedom
and the Corrections,
for which he won a
National Book Award.
And numerous other prizes.
And five works of
nonfiction and translation.
Ladies and gentlemen, will you
please welcome Jonathan Franzen?
[ Applause ]
So I'd like to start
with a quote, Jon.
If everyone can hear me.
Can I, can I be heard?
Yes? This is from Sam
Tanenhaus at the New York Times.
He said, "Franzen cracks
open the opaque shell
of postmodernism.
Tweezes out its tangled
circuitry,
and inserts in its place,
the warm beating heart
of an authentic humanism."
>> Jonathan Franzen:
That was nice of Sam.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marie Arana: "He writes with
equal fluency on equity finance,
railroad engineering, currency
manipulation in Eastern Europe.
The neurochemistry of
clinical depression.
But the data flows through
the arteries of narrative.
Attending to the quiet
drama of interior life
and recording its
fraught transactions
with a public world."
Now that is a pretty
big, tall order.
Jon, you write about
dysfunctional families.
Small American worlds that are
exploded really by large events.
I think I can summarize
your work that way.
And the humdrum of, of quiet
lives that are suddenly ripped
to shreds by foreign
events or economic busts.
Or miscommunications.
Of happenstance.
What brings you to
those subjects?
[ Laughter ]
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Sheer desperation.
That's kind of what you face
every morning in the office.
First of all, thank
you all for coming.
I, I never do these things.
There's only one writer I
would have done this for.
And that's Denis
Johnson because he has,
he has a unique place, actually.
In the world of American
literature.
He's the one writer who every
writer I know can quote multiple
lines from verbatim.
They are often very funny lines.
Which is something I
hope we don't lose sight
of as Denis was one of the
funniest writers we had.
Laugh-out-loud funny.
Precisely because he was
so close to the edge.
So it's, it's an
honor to be here,
and I'm so glad Cindy
can be here too.
So oh, yeah.
My work. [Clears throat]
It's autobiographical.
It's just to get at the
stuff that I'm interested in.
I, I, I'm very bad at
writing about myself.
I think there are
two kinds of writers.
One who can pretty much only
write about himself or herself.
And then the other kind
and I'm the other kind.
And I, I like a good story.
And typically, good stories are
about characters who want stuff.
And also if they're anxious,
then the story might be funny.
And if, if I'm not laughing,
then I am just setting
those pages aside
and trying something else.
And I, and I guess, yes.
And I always paid
attention to the news.
I had a dad who was very attuned
to, he was just, he'd had no,
he had no education really.
Except, as a, as
a civil engineer.
But he, he thought about stuff.
And you know, dinner table
conversation when I was growing
up would be what was
happening in the world.
So that just seemed natural.
And also it's nice if you have
a character who wants something
to put it, to put that character
in a recognizable world.
And I, it doesn't seem,
it just seems like yeah.
It's, it's what I do.
That was a sort of
inarticulate response.
But the articulate
response would eat
up the rest of our time.
>> Marie Arana: Well,
you're pretty articulate
on the page, Jon.
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Where it counts.
[Laughter]
>> Marie Arana: Where it counts.
The but you, you, you
really do, I think,
more than many American writers
who are dealing perhaps
with, you know.
Plot-driven or, or shall we
say small domestic troubles.
That there is a sense
that, there is a sense
when you read Jonathan Franzen
that you are reading something
about this anxious age.
Something about a, a kind of
loss of connectivity that we've,
that we seem to have come to.
At least that's what
the critics say.
What do you say from your perch?
About what you're trying to do?
>> Jonathan Franzen: Honestly,
I am trying to be funny.
And I, and I find people who are
anxious very funny because I,
I feel that's the only way
to survive my own anxiety.
Is to step back and throw
it into somebody else,
and then laugh at that person.
So for instance, like
in the Corrections, I,
I spent so I'm always looking
for a topic sentence that,
this is a little craft thing.
I don't really have a character
until I can write a good topic
sentence about that character.
It all goes back to what we
were taught in seventh grade
about topic sentences.
It turns out to be
really, really true.
And it, and it can take
up to five years to come
up with a topic sentence for
a character for me [laughter].
But there was a character
in The Corrections, Gary,
who and it was a rather
elaborate topic sentence,
but it basically had to do with.
He had, there was all this
attention in the nineties
on clinical depression.
Which Prozac was the,
the miracle cure for.
And he, he basically he
was trying to demonstrate
that he was not clinically.
He was trying to do something in
order to demonstrate to his wife
that he was not clinically
depressed.
So that's, that was right
very much of the time.
And there were, people
were having conversations--
it became.
Instead of saying, "I don't,
I wish you would take the trash
out, or I wish you would clean
up after dinner more."
They would say, "You
have a problem,
You're clinically depressed."
And then the other
person would say, "No,
I'm not clinically depressed.
You're clinically depressed."
[Laughter] And so
it was hilarious
but those were real fights.
And I had been in one myself.
It was like-- .
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so it's like
okay, well now I kind
of got a handle on this guy.
That the, and, and yes,
it does, it does draw
in what's happening
in the world.
Because why not?
It's fun. Yeah.
I, I mean, I'm an entertainer.
I'm looking for what's fun.
>> Marie Arana: So
let me ask you now.
Talking about real life because
one of the things that I,
I think would be
really interesting
to explore particularly
with your work.
Is the, is the way that
fiction in some ways gets
across a reality better than
sometimes nonfiction can.
What does fiction in
your mind, what does it,
how does it do that
for a society?
How does it feed us?
How does it, how does it
nurture us in that sense?
>> Jonathan Franzen: I
actually think the people
who read Denis Johnson-level
fiction are the lucky ones.
And I don't mean
economically the lucky ones.
I mean just lucky.
Something is going right
if you can actually sustain
attention in a novel.
If you're really, really
miserable, you can't do that.
And in the prison population,
there are the readers,
and those are the lucky ones.
In any population it's,
it's actually so if you,
if you could enjoy a book.
You should pause for a
moment with gratitude
that you're able to do that.
Because a lot of people can't.
If you can enjoy a
complicated dark book,
that laughs at other things,
at things other people
might find terrible.
Then you're really,
really lucky.
But that, but that is actually
almost a definition of,
of what we call literature.
Is that kind of cosmic
distance on stuff.
If you're really down in the
trenches, you can't do that.
Oh yeah, so I think of, I talk
a lot about the metamorphosis,
Kafka's novel about Gregor
Samsa who wakes up one morning
and finds that he's an insect.
He could have done a memoir, a
sort of midstream memoir talking
about how crappy it was to
live at home with his parents.
And not even have
the good bedroom,
even though he was
the son and so forth.
[Laughter] As a grown
man, you know,
he's been working
a job for years.
And there he is at
home with the parents.
And he could have
probably gotten across some
of why he found that a drag.
But to get at really the
degree to which he experienced
that as unbelievably
terrible, he made up a story.
He invented something.
And, and also in the, in the
process, good thing for fiction,
he protected his family.
Because [laughter] everyone knew
that the Kafka's did not
have a large bug for a son.
So they, the parents
said, "Oh, it's not us."
[Laughter] How could that be us?
Franz is a little weird,
but he's not an insect.
[Laughter] So and I think
that broadly speaking,
that's a metaphor for
what fiction does.
Is it, it enables you
to, to go, to exaggerate
in these wild ways that, that
mere representation of reality.
The states of mind, states,
emotional states and lots
of other kinds of states.
That mere factual
representation simply cannot.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah.
Of course that brings me,
you're, you're, you're talking
about the, the ways
that fiction works.
I mean, the humor in fiction
which, which Denis used
so superbly in the
middle the darkest sort
of funkiest moments.
It would, you would find
it screamingly funny.
>> Jonathan Franzen: His word
choice in a Fatal Accident,
the first story in Jesus' Son.
Even I think, I think, when
the, when the car crash happens,
the woman says, "No," the
woman said viciously."
Like that word viciously.
Which is like a head-on
crash is about to occur.
Yeah. That's, that tells me
he had resolved something.
And could see it from the kind
of perspective from which-- .
On the one hand, he's sort
of touching close to God.
And on the other hand,
he's touching his,
it's all hilarious.
If you, if you get the new story
collection for no other reason,
there's a two and
a half page scene
of the narrator having
a knee examination.
In surgical theater while
tripping on LSD that,
if there's any doubt that
he was a comic writer.
Yeah.
>> Marie Arana: In
fact you, you,
you made a wonderful citation
at his prize ceremony.
And I want to read
at least part of it.
You said, "His sentences at best
are miracles of transparency
and tone," which
we've already heard.
"Perfect in the way they inhabit
the page, but devoid of vanity
about their perfection.
Always vivid in their
reference to the actual
but also always conveying
something larger.
Their creator's own
self-knowledge and compassion
and sense of cosmic comedy.
The God I want to believe in
has a voice like Johnson's."
>> Jonathan Franzen: Right.
>> Marie Arana: What is-- .
[Laughter]
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Oh, I don't know.
Stress on "want to".
As in wish I could.
But yeah, if, I mean, if there
were a God who spoke like,
you know, in with that kind of.
I'm not going to try to
explicate that sentence.
>> Marie Arana: Okay.
[Laughter] I think
what it meant-- .
>> Jonathan Franzen: Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
>> Marie Arana: If I may.
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Absolutely may.
[Laughter]
>> Marie Arana: Is that
he really had a voice.
I mean a very strong voice.
And it was, if, if, if we could
put a, if we could pinpoint
that talent, it would be
that, that voice that he had.
That was absolutely
unique and original.
As yours is, I would say.
That, that sense that, that
sense that you are in the hands
of a really superb narrator
and you can't quite let go.
It's mesmerizing.
That voice.
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Well thank you.
>> Marie Arana: Is
that what you meant?
[Laughter]
>> Jonathan Franzen: I was
not talking about myself.
I was talking about Denis.
But.
Yeah.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah.
>> Jonathan Franzen: What was--
I, I thought actually that
Marilynne put it nicely,
that there was, there is a
sense of a kind of unitary.
That, that what he,
that the writing and,
and the person were
almost indistinguishable.
It strikes me and I think
our other two guests
who will soon join
me can speak to this.
He is somebody who might
very well not have survived.
He was, he was a kind
of messed up kid.
And had intimate knowledge with
these, you know, pretty violent
and definitely addictive
situations.
And there is a, there is
a sense of at the core
of I think all of his.
I, I was rereading The New
Stories on the way down here.
And what, what the
whole book kind of feels
like a meditation--
not a meditation.
It's, it's a representation
of the amazingness
of still being alive?
So that there's something
about everything he wrote
that is aware of the
proximity of death.
And that, that goes to in
that respect there's a,
I think there's a kind of
subterranean connection
with Flannery O'Connor
who in her, the greatest
of all of her great stories.
Good Man is Hard to Find,
she would have been a good woman
had there been someone there
to shoot her every
day of her life.
[ Laughter ]
About the grandmother
in that story.
If you don't know the
story, go read it.
Which is basically this is,
this was a trivial woman
who with a gun pointed at
her, suddenly found something.
And somehow, throughout
his career,
he managed to write the stuff
that felt right on that bubble
of there's a gun pointed at me.
Death is all around me.
I've seen people die.
I'm aware that I'm going to die.
And you know, there's
a line in the new book,
you know, "I like my wife.
She's you know, clever
and rather attractive.
She can die any minute."
And then he just says that.
It's like, and then
new paragraph,
we're onto the rest
of the story.
But that's, that seemed to me
kind of the essence of the work.
That's why, what makes
it so exciting is
that there's always
death right there.
>> Marie Arana: Right there.
>> Jonathan Franzen: Yeah.
Right there.
>> Marie Arana: Well,
with death right there,
let's bring on Elliot Ackerman.
[ Applause ]
So here's a quote.
>> Elliot Ackerman:
First of all,
that might be my
favorite introduction.
>> Marie Arana: Here, here's
a quote to accompany you
to have you accompany us.
As, as I did for Jon.
This is from Ben Fountain,
who wrote a wonderful book
called Billy Lynn's Wonderful
Halftime Walk, if you know it.
And he wrote about Elliot this.
"Dark at the Crossing is every
bit as taut and harrowing
as the place it depicts.
A region where 15 years
of relentless war play
out in filthy refugee camps
and upscale shopping malls.
Elliot Ackerman has written
a brilliant, admirably,
merciless novel of broken
lives, broken places,
and good intentions gone awry."
Someone once said of you, if
I remember this correctly.
That they, they don't award
medals of valor for writing.
But maybe they should to you.
There's a sense, Elliot, in
your books, both of them.
That you have emerged
from the cauldron
of hell to tell this story.
How, this is going
to, this is going
to make Jon's blood pressure
rise because I read somewhere
that he hates this question.
I'm going to ask this question.
How autobiographical
are these stories?
In the sense that you
have lived through any--
of course you've lived
through, through,
through the hell of war.
But to what extent
are these from life?
>> Elliot Ackerman: Well,
I mean, you know, my,
my first book is, is the story
of an Afghan who's
murdered by an American.
It's all told from the
perspective of the Afghan.
So that's not me.
And you know my, my second novel
takes place in southern Turkey
around the Syrian civil
war and it's a love story.
But those characters aren't me.
However, they are deeply
informed by my experience.
And I don't think I could
extricate my experiences
from the book.
>> Marie Arana: Right,
but there's a, there,
there is a sense, I think,
especially in Green on Blue.
That you are, you're not
sure what side is which.
It reminds me of revolutions
in which the sides keep
changing all the time.
Because people see the
battle's going this way,
the battle's going that way.
And they're going to run to
whatever side is winning.
There's that, there's a, a,
that sense of divided loyalties
or confused loyalties.
And the fog of it
all in a sense.
That, and that's clearly
something that you've seen.
>> Elliot Ackerman: I mean,
it's something that I've seen
and something that I admire.
You know, in other
people's writing.
It's something I admired
in Denis Johnson's writing.
You know, the ability to take
extremely complex political
events and make them
feel extremely personal.
I think it's something
that, that fiction does.
But then you get a, you know,
we were talking about you know,
different sides of an issue.
You know, in a war.
Like for instance, there's a,
what's the trope someone just
said to me the other day.
Which is you know, you, maybe
it was said on television.
You don't really know a person
until you've been
divorced from them.
Which is you know like
that' probably true.
You know I would append to that
you don't really know a person
until you know you've fought
on the opposite side
of a war from them.
And so I think there's sort of,
and sometimes we'll see
you know, it's, you know,
why are you so, you know
fascinated by the people
on the other sides
of these conflicts?
Well in some ways they're the
people that you know the best
until you trot out
another tired trope.
You know, write what you know.
And you know, and oftentimes you
know, you know them the best.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
But I, I assume that in, in,
in particularly in, in Iraq
and Afghanistan you are
fighting alongside people who,
who are of that land.
And with whom you have to,
you have to make bonds.
I mean one thing I think that
you've said so eloquently.
Is that a Marine is
trained to kill, right?
But he also has to
be trained to love.
And why? Because he has to
throw himself in the line
of fire for his buddy.
For his compatriot.
For the person he's,
he's, he's fighting with.
And that really interests me,
that notion of you know, you're,
you're essentially
falling in love with,
or loving a person who,
whose life is at risk.
And who may, who
will die or may die.
>> Elliot Ackerman: I think
it gets to sort of the,
the topic of our panel here.
And what is very unique in
Johnson's work is that he is
so often on the edge, or I
would say it's also almost
like this extremely thin
membrane that is translucent
when you're standing
there right up against.
You know, issues,
particularly issues
of conflict, you know, in wars.
And who are fascinated
by that subject.
You know the difference
between, you know,
love and violence
is so permeable.
And so I mean I found
in my own experience.
I have found in my
own experience in war.
Even some, some of the great
ironies is that you know people,
you know, are doing very,
very courageous things.
Because they love one another.
But the courageous things
that they're doing are
incredibly violent.
And so, so again, you're
constantly, you know, flipping.
You know, permeating
that membrane.
>> Marie Arana: Speaking
of membranes,
the Darkness at the Crossing.
Deal with, a, an Iraqi
who's actually born in Iraq,
but he's an American citizen.
We can't but wonder
as we read it.
And he wonders it himself,
where his loyalties lie.
And what it means to
be true to oneself
when you have two
identities at work.
Two nationalities at work.
Two, you know, loyalties.
And how did you get
to that subject?
And how, how, how does that,
how did that come to you?
>> Elliot Ackerman: Well
you know, this character
who is an Arab American
basically decides he wants
to go cross into Syria to, to
fight for the Free Syrian Army.
And a lot of the book is about
unpacking his motivations.
And actually kind of gets
to what Jon was just saying
with the Flannery
O'Connor story.
About needing the gun
pointed at your head.
Which also reminds
me of the great scene
in Stanley Kubrick's
Full Metal Jacket.
About Animal Mother, the machine
gunner in the Marine platoon.
And they say, you know,
Animal Mother's a great guy.
He just needs someone to
throw hand grenades at him
for the rest of his life.
[Laughter] And so, you
know, this character,
Harris [inaudible] is kind of
the, he's in the same position.
But you know, and to
be honest with you.
The, the, the thing
that was foremost
in my mind wasn't anything that
happened to me in the wars.
It was actually a
scene in Anna Karenina
and the way Anna Karenina ends.
And so and the spoiler alert--
she throws herself in front of
a train and commits suicide.
[Laughter] But, but you know,
I always felt like reading
that book and getting
[inaudible] at like Vronsky,
her lover, kind of
gets like a bad rap.
I feel like, you know, like the
world's been tough on Vronsky.
And if you recall,
the last you ever hear
of Vronsky, he's been disgraced.
He's an outcast from
society now.
But the last we hear is like
you don't even see Vronsky.
You don't, you don't
see Vronsky.
You're just told by
another character
that Vronsky was last seen on
a train heading to the caucasus
to rejoin his regiment.
And they don't say why and
of course he's on a train.
Anna just threw herself
in front of train.
And you know, Tolstoy
doesn't tell you the reasons.
But it always fascinated me
is you know he could be going
to rejoin his regiment.
Because he thinks that some you
know battlefield heroics will be
the way he can redeem himself.
And integrate again
into society.
Okay, or he could be
going there to basically.
He could be on that train for
the same reasons, you know,
as Anna ended herself.
He'll be going off to
war to kill himself.
And you don't know, and
you never get the answer
from Tolstoy.
And you know I have always
been fascinated that how,
you know people can
engage in one act.
People can go to war for,
for completely different,
you know for reasons they
don't even know themselves.
And they can be an
act, a redemptive act.
Or it can be a destructive act.
So that's something
that you know that,
that I was hoping to examine.
>> Marie Arana: Well,
you, you as, as,
as Denis did in,
in Tree of Smoke.
That, that sense of
you know the, the,
the complete suspension in a
kind of wildcard situation.
>> Elliot Ackerman: Well like in
Angels, you know, which is one
of my favorite books of his.
You know you have this
sort of like kind of.
It's not banal, but it
seems like everyday.
It opens on a bus.
I mean, you know, there's a guy,
you know who's meeting
a woman on a bus.
She's got her kid.
You know and by the, you get to
the end of it and you're going,
you're in the middle
of a bank robbery.
And the way he could just sort
of slip you from the banal
into the very, very violent.
And put you in situations
you kind
of can't imagine that you're in.
You know I think was the
wonderful thing he did
in his work.
And I aspire to do
it in my work.
Particularly when you're
dealing with violence.
Because the thing
we often forget
about violence is it
is, it is so banal.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
The dealing with violence, it
seems to me you know, the, the,
the, the, it's so physical.
It's so concrete and it's,
it's, it's all around you.
And yet and you deal with
these war situations.
But you also said at
one point, Elliot, you,
you quote actually
quote Faulkner.
In which you say
the only, he said,
"The only thing worth writing
about is the human heart
in conflict with itself."
That being the conflict.
Not being the conflict
that's around you concretely.
And, and possibly
threatening your life.
It seems what interests you
more is the internal conflict
that is going on.
Even as that conflict
is happening.
>> Elliot Ackerman: Well,
I think it's a [inaudible]
that interests most people.
I mean, characters
are interesting.
It's, you know, it's
once you start getting
into you know you
were talking before
about you know what
does fiction do?
You know, fiction takes you
into the internal
lives of these people.
And I think that's, that's
where you know that's
where the most compelling
stories arise.
You know and that's where
the, the emotion exists.
And you know why write fiction
I think you know if you are able
to make someone feel something.
You know there'll
remember what they felt.
In a way they might not
remember what they read
in the paper that morning.
>> Marie Arana: One
last question for you.
And that is, you're a warrior.
>> Elliot Ackerman:
On my good days.
[ Laughter ]
Marie Arana: You know, warriors
come home and things happen.
And do, do we and I'm, I'm
trying to take this out to,
to a, a more social or
political question, if you will.
Why do we revere warriors?
I mean, we revere
warriors from afar.
When they come home, when they
are riddled with problems.
When you know they may be
addicted to drugs or, or,
or beating their
wives or you know,
a female beating her husbands.
Or not being good
to the children.
How, why is it that
we're not so good
at confronting those
issues that they bring home?
>> Elliot Ackerman: Well,
I think in some respects it's
easy you know at that point
to look at them as the other.
You know I've often,
probably most people
who have my background
have, have the experience
of you know someone
saying to them.
Like you know I could never
imagine what you went through.
I'm like, yeah you can.
Sure you can.
Like you know, you
can, maybe you've
like passed by a car accident.
Or you know you've lost
someone in your own family.
But I think at the same time
like saying I can never
imagine what you went through.
Like always is unsettled to me.
Not only because it kind
of shows, like you know,
because it, because
it's, puts up some
like lack of you know empathy.
It's like if you can never
imagine what I went through,
or what someone went
through in this.
Then what you're basically
saying is that like I have been
so inalterably changed or one
has been so inalterably changed
by an experience that you can
no longer identify with them.
So if you can't understand
what I went through.
It means I have been
so unalterably changed
that I can never go back
to being the person
I was before I left.
If I can never go back to being
the person I was before I left,
it in effect means I
can never come home.
And that's, you know,
and that's, that's,
that's somewhere we,
we just can't be.
So, so I think that you know
that, that maybe the answer
to your question is you know
just a general lack of empathy.
And lack of being able
to you know see ourselves
collectively you know
in these wars.
>> Marie Arana: Right, right.
And with that, I want to
bring on Sam Quinones,
who deals with issues of-- .
[ Applause ]
And, and here's what I
want to read about Sam.
This was written by, by
Laura Miller at Slate.
"Many nonfiction books are
padded magazine features.
But Dreamland, the
three-pronged story
of how heroin addiction
become, became epidemic
in small town America.
Is the book Quinones
has to quit his job
at the L.A. Times to write.
You won't find this story
better told anywhere else.
From the economic hollowing-out
of the middle class.
To the greedy, reckless
marketing
of pharmaceutical opiates
to the remarkable
entrepreneurial industry
of the residents of the obscure
Mexican state of Nayarit.
All of these factors combine
to create an opiate-addicted
population
in small American cities
like Portsmouth, Ohio.
Where residents, priced
out of pill mills,
turn to a new and
newly cheap high.
Dreamland, true crime, sociology
and expose illuminates a
catastrophe unfolding all
around us, right now."
Sam, you've covered the border.
You've covered US-Mexico
relations.
You've been a Latin
American correspondent for,
for many, many years.
At what point did the opioid
crisis get your attention?
>> Sam Quinones: Well I, I
began a story about when I was
at the L.A. Times about
a small town in Mexico.
Where everybody comes
to the United States
to sell heroin like pizza.
So there's a delivery system
where you call a number
and then you have the
operator takes your order
and then dispatches someone.
To, to meet you when-- it's a,
it's basically Domino's
Pizza of heroin.
I came upon it when I was
talking a guy with the DEA
in Columbus who said, "You know,
we've got this system here.
We've got these guys doing this.
We've never seen this before.
No guns, they don't use guns.
They're, they're, they're
and we can arrest them
and arrest them and arrest them.
And they send out more people.
They reconstitute like
a, like a some kind
of a mutant, very quickly."
And he said, "They're
all from the same town."
And that, I had written, I had
lived in Mexico for ten years.
And I had written a lot
about you see this
a lot across Mexico.
Where towns have,
whereas one town,
towns where people do one job.
And, and there's one town in
my first book where everybody
in the town makes popsicles.
One of the great businesses,
businesses for arriving
at the middle class in Mexico
is the popsicle business.
And there's a business,
if you know Mexico,
you know, Paleteria.
That means [inaudible]
is everywhere.
And that's one town
started that.
And, and you go to the town,
and there's a, in the front
of the town, there's a two-story
concrete popsicle statue.
Saying thank you to the
popsicle for bringing them
into the middle class.
So when you told me that,
I knew he was right.
I knew there had to
be a town out there.
He didn't know which one.
He said it was Tepic, Nayarit.
I knew it was not Tepic.
Tepic is a capital city, 350,000
people of the state of Nayarit.
I knew that could not be true.
It had to be a small town.
So I began to write to
guys who had been arrested
and were now in federal prison.
And one after another, I wrote
20, 30 letters to these guys.
Hey, do you want to talk about
your pizza heroin system?
You know, basically
is what I did.
And one guy, one guy
kind of got back to me.
Says, yeah.
We're not from Tepic, we're from
little town called [inaudible].
All are heroin traffickers.
And I thought at the time it
was just Columbus because that's
where I first encountered those.
Then he began to
say, "Oh, no, no.
We're all over the country."
And I could not explain a
few things by, about that.
First of all, they, they
sell black tar heroin.
And my understanding,
my knowledge
of black tar heroin was fairly
extensive at that point.
And black tar heroin is
really for many years only
on the western side
of the United States.
What, and now they were
selling in Columbus and really
in West Virginia and places in
Tennessee, places like that.
And he began to say,
tell all the cities
where they were located now,
and they had moved to Charlotte,
and they had moved to Lexington
and Cincinnati and Memphis
and Nashville and Indianapolis,
et cetera, et cetera.
All these different towns
on the eastern side of,
of the United States.
And could not explain
why it would be
that heroin traffickers
would have such big business.
Such a new market.
I thought heroin
was this old thing
that no one really
messed with anymore.
Everyone knew it was a disaster.
So why would you actually
mess around with, with heroin?
Why would there be
new, huge new numbers
of people buying this drug?
And, and using, and
using this drug?
And, and that's really what
got me onto the larger story
which is the pain pills and the
opioids as we know them today.
But it was really an
attempt to understand why,
why Mexican heroin
traffickers, particularly
from this one town where I went.
I interviewed eventually a dozen
or so, maybe ten or 12 guys
who were traffickers, who
were all in federal prison.
From this town.
And it was a wave.
But I understood them to
be the vanguard of this.
That they were, they were,
the, the spear really under,
finding the market that
was then going to explode.
Which has now happened.
But they were, they
found this market.
They knew what was going to
happen back in 1998, '99, 2000,
what's happening today, all
across the country basically.
>> Marie Arana: Could you tell
us a little bit about the scale?
You testified in
Congress not long ago
and I watched the whole hearing.
It was absolutely fascinating.
And, and I recommend it.
Opioids kill people every day.
In a scale, I think
you said in the hearing
that more people are
killed by opiates
than by car accidents
in this country.
Tell us about the scale
that we're talking about.
The scale.
>> Sam Quinones: The scale?
Is, is quite stunning, I think.
Yes, I mean, it,
it must have been.
One of the great moments or
the fascinating moments, I,
I describe in my book is
when two public health folks
from the state of Ohio.
Realize that there is about
to be a historic shift.
Since in modern America,
the automobile has always
been the leading cause
of accidental death.
There has never been a time,
and now of course
that's gotten better.
You know, we've gotten
more, we've gotten safer.
You know better cars, et cetera.
So that number was coming down.
But in [inaudible] public
health people at the state
of Ohio figured out that
that was going to end.
That there was now in the state
of Ohio first the narcot--
overdoses mostly to
narcotics, pain pills.
But to some degree
heroin at that point.
Was overtaking and was going
to be the number-one
cause of death.
And that was true
in Ohio in 2007,
and then it was true
nationally the next year.
And, and it's a, it's a,
it's a stunning thing.
I think it's also very
much an undercount.
Because this story begins and
is most intensely felt in states
with too many counties.
And too many counties like
Kentucky has 120 counties
for four million people.
Ohio, Ohio has 88 counties
for 11 million people.
West Virginia has
55 counties for less
than two million people.
And the reason that's important
is because this is not like,
I was a crime reporter.
Started my career
in the crack days.
And crack was very public.
Everything about it was public.
You couldn't avoid it.
It was on the streets.
Drive-by shootings, the gangs
were growing very wealthy and,
and violent and armed.
And, and you know
homicide rates went up
and the violence was horrible.
And it destroyed neighborhoods.
And none of that was
happening with this.
In fact, crime rates
were dropping as,
as overdose rates were also,
were, were, were, were rising.
And so you have this, this
kind of transformation of, of,
of what you normally think of.
As very quiet, right?
The doctors were the,
were the source of supply.
This really starts with
narcotic painkillers.
Not heroin.
The traffickers come later.
So it's really a, so the
suppliers are doctors,
pharmaceutical companies.
American patients to
be fixed in a sense.
And so and, and, and at the
same time you have parents
and families wanting
to hide the fact
that their kids are addicted.
Nobody wants to be recognizing
that the obituaries are almost
all fabrications and so on.
So the only place you're
going to find this.
The place where we're going
to recognize this is the
coroner's office, bodies.
But the problem is in these
small counties, in these states
with too few, too many counties.
The counties, we fund coroner's
offices erroneously, mistakenly,
I believe, based on
country tax base.
And so these coroner's
offices are small.
They're underfunded frequently.
They don't have enough
doctors in these areas.
And they have they're, they're,
they're susceptible
to family influence.
So you know doc, don't
tell, don't put that in the,
in the death report
because it's going
to look bad for, for my dad.
Or my brother or my, my,
my child or what have you.
And so what's happening today
is really I believe like a,
an enormous plague
across the country.
Certainly in large
parts of the country.
It's very, very intensely felt.
That is, that is
consuming families.
Consuming neighborhoods.
Consuming football teams.
Football is really
basically now a, a,
a gateway to heroin addiction
in America, in my opinion.
It, it's, it's, and it's also
destroying those areas that,
in order for those areas to be
great again, lot of these areas.
They have to defeat
this problem.
Because now, nobody is actually
going to go put a factory
in some areas where half
the population can't pass a
drug test.
You know, and so it's,
the effect is, is massive.
And it's, and it's, but on, but
also for a long time, it really.
[Inaudible] when my
book came out, the,
the health policy advisor for
Hillary Clinton called me.
And said, "Hillary is stunned."
This is 2015.
"She's in Ohio-- she's in Iowa
and she's in New Hampshire,
and she's stunned
by the ferocity
with which she's seeing
parents come to her and say.
'We need a solution.'"
They didn't care
about almost anything else.
Right? And I said
yes because first
of all this is a this is
a topic that polls poorly.
You're never going to get
somebody to admit on the phone
that this is their most
important subject, right?
They want to hide it.
But go out there.
Hug people.
Be a mother to people.
They need that.
And you know, they're probably
a lot of reasons she lost.
But, but she, to that she
wrote a policy position paper.
And that was, you know.
So my feeling is this is
a very hidden, even today.
Even though the awareness
is much greater
than it ever has been.
Even today it's still,
we're seeing the,
these, these icebergs.
And really down below
is a massive,
massive issue that's
everywhere in our country.
>> Marie Arana: Veterans
in pain?
Or people in, that
recreational as well?
I mean, it, it seems to do
the gamut, the spectrum.
>> Sam Quinones: Right,
but it's also, yes, sure.
But it's all, all
connected to this idea
that took hold in the mid-1990s.
That promoted by
pain specialists.
And by pharmaceutical companies.
And really eagerly accepted by
us, American health consumers.
That narcotic pain
killers were now known
to be virtually nonaddictive
when used to treat pain.
And therefore, the
corollary, the damaging coro--
the dangerous corollary to all
that was it doesn't
matter how many
of these pills you
get prescribed.
And you, you probably have gone,
many of you I'm sure have
gone in for a surgery.
The pain for which is
going to last what?
Two to three days?
You get 30 days'
worth of pills, right?
Well, you multiply
that by millions
of Americans every
year for 20 years.
And what you get is a massive
supply that has created a,
therefore, a massive
black market.
And so you get kids going
to parties and saying,
the quarterback is, on the
high school football team is
taking them.
So well damn, I'll take them.
I mean, most of the
addiction is,
is related in my
opinion to supply.
Used to believe that, that,
that our addiction
problems were due to demand.
And when you're in Mexico,
it's nice to believe that.
Mexicans want to believe.
It helps them kind
of wash their hands
of our bi-national drug problem.
Well, it's those
gringos up there.
They just want their dope.
Well the truth is not that.
I was, I was convinced of that
when I was living in Mexico.
Now I'm, I'm not.
I, I, I convinced, I'm convinced
now that it's the supply issue.
And most drug problems are.
You unleash a, a vast,
people come to me and say,
"Should we legalize drugs?"
[Inaudible] in this book?
And I'm like well what
about this story makes
you believe we ought
to legalize drugs?
All of this is due
to legal drugs.
You unleash a vast, vast
hyper, very potent supply
of legal drugs on
a, on a population.
And, and you will get
massive problems, you know.
And it was, it was a time
of, of fantasy, you know?
I often point out these were
years too when we believed that,
that many we, we believed
kind of we were special.
And therefore old rules
don't apply to us.
You know? And so these
were years you know when,
when we believed
it was very common
for numerous baseball players
to hit more than 60 home runs.
And it happened twice, you know?
And it has not happened since.
They cracked down
on steroids, right?
We believe that if
you package all these,
all these non-performing nasty
home loans into one security
and Standard & Poor
stamps that thing triple A,
that's a magnificent place
to, to put your money.
And we believed that you
massively prescribe narcotics
derived from the opium poppy.
That that would not
create some, you know,
enormous new population
of drug addiction.
And very much unlike the
subjects of Denis Johnson.
These are, these are
mainstream people.
I had a drug addict tell
me, "Dude, I stopped using.
It was enough to get me
to stop using to watch
when the football players and
the cheerleaders got addicted."
Because he was a punk rocker.
He didn't want to be, he
went to heroin because it was
like this outside kind of thing.
Rebel kind of thing.
Now it's very much mainstream.
>> Marie Arana: This is what
I was trying to point out.
In, in one of the short stories
in Largesse of the Sea Maiden,
which was just published
posthumously,
by, by Random House.
Wonderful book, absolutely
marvelous book of short stories.
In many ways, I think
a culmination of,
of Denis' talent.
He writes about a jail
bird's ability to get high
on the most unexpected
of substances.
That at one point,
somebody brings
in a newspaper soaked in LSD.
And everybody just thinks well
that's just a newspaper except
that it's, you know,
it's satisfying.
This is a very different
thing that you're describing.
This is not, this is,
it's, it's jump-- .
>> Sam Quinones: This is
almost entirely white people.
This is, it starts in
Appalachia and the Rust Belt.
Which of course that is
where, where, we're very eager
to ignore and did ignore.
But by the time I
got onto the story,
really it had spread
far, far beyond.
And really had spread
across America.
And had spread really,
stunningly, in my opinion
to some of the, the
very nicest suburbs.
Orange County is like our heroin
beltway in L.A. now, you know.
Some of the nicest suburbs
where people had done best
in the economic expansions of
the previous say 20 or 30 years.
It was in those areas, I've
always thought it was stunning.
That in those areas, people are,
were getting addicted and dying
from drugs used to numb pain.
Like you look at their
lives, and you go,
well what pain exactly
do you feel?
They have the perfect life
in the history of the world,
.0001% have lived,
of the people ever
to exist have lived
as well as you.
And you've got to, you know,
use these, use these drugs to?"
But, but I mean, I, I think
that that's kind of the story
that I, I initially believed.
That I was writing the great
American drug trafficking story.
I want to be, I was
a crime reporter.
That's really all I
wanted to do, you know?
I wanted to write about
Mexico and all the crime
and gangs and all this stuff.
And then I began to
realize no, that, well yes.
This is certainly that story.
But there's a whole
lot more to it.
There's, there's,
there's, there's isolat--
really what it comes
down to is not economics.
How do you say a Rust
Belt town in Charlotte,
North Carolina had
the same problem.
And make it an economics-- ?
It's not an economics.
Or when it really has
to do with, I believe,
my common denominator
with the best I can come
up with is our own deep
and profound isolation.
And our destruction
of community.
Which is why I chose the,
this pool, swimming pool
in a small town called
Portsmouth,
Ohio, on the Ohio River.
For the metaphor really,
the, the central issue,
image of the, of the book.
It, the name of the
pool was Dreamland,
and the pool was a place
where everyone came together
and got, and, and grew up.
And was a steel mill
and shoe factories
and bustling Main
Street and all that.
And 50,000 people,
and the pool was
where they all came together
and formed community.
And then of course
the steel mill leaves.
The, the, the shoe
factories leave.
The, the, the Main
Street just empties out.
Classic fashion.
Half the town leaves.
And then everyone
retreats indoors.
And finally they can't
sustain it, and they dig up
and destroy Dreamland.
And replace it with
a, with a strip mall
and an O'Reilly's Auto
Parts store as the, as the,
the, the anchor tenant.
And, and then they
become exposed.
Not unlike I believe the,
the Indians when the
Europeans brought smallpox.
You know it, it just became.
They had no bulwark, community
bulwark to keep this at bay.
And I think that that, that is
what we're, what we're dealing
with now in a deeper sense.
Kind of with this, with this
opioid epidemic that is,
you know, coast to coast.
>> Marie Arana: This is what
struck me about your hearing.
And I want to bring Jon
into this because you said
in the hearing that
it was at that point.
Where you know families from
all kinds of classes and,
and would get together
and, and [inaudible].
This was their, you know, the,
the community coming together.
And a kind of, of, of real
connect-- connectedness there.
And so much of what Jon writes
about is a kind of disconnect.
Where you're reeling out
of connection, really.
Because you know it either,
your marriage is falling apart.
Your, your, the economy
has, has, has gone bust.
And you don't have a job in,
in, in, in the mining town.
So.
My, my question is and this
is a Pollyanna question,
I, I, I admit.
Fix the malaise,
fix the problem,
fix this disconnectedness.
Jon, what do you think?
And, and you start to-- because
I think you actually said
in the hearing, Sam.
You said, you've got
to get back to that.
You've got to get back
to that connection.
to that community.
What do you think, Jon?
>> Jonathan Franzen: I, I would,
I would respectfully disagree
that I write about
dysfunctional families.
I think, I think the
dysfunctional families are
likely to be found where
there is a substance.
I, in fact, write about
highly functional families.
The kids are all
well taken care of.
They're not dropped
on their head.
There are in fact no
serious drug addictions.
And yeah, I'm an old leftist.
And I actually think that you
know just, we've been ground
between the twin grinding
plates of consumerism and kind
of which is an atomizing force.
It makes the individual consumer
the most important thing.
And in fact, I would
actually flip it around
and say the reason I'm writing
about families is I think
of the family as the one
thing that you can't.
No matter how hard
the two plates grind,
you can't actually
dissolve the family bond.
So if you're interested
in psychological
intensity in a novel.
Which is kind of catnip
for me, you're naturally,
you're naturally
drawn to the family.
Because that's like one of the
few places you can find it.
You're not going to
find it necessarily
at the community level or
even at the friendship level.
Because of this.
So yeah, I, I, I do think
that this, and then of course.
Corporate pharmaceutical forces
and then, and you know all
of those things you
were mentioning.
And then the financial industry.
The, the worst of
capitalism is kind of piling
on to make these things worse.
>> Sam Quinones: I think
heroin's interesting to me
because it dawns on
me that that is--
piggybacking on what
you're saying.
Is that that is, if you
are a culture that believes
that stuff will buy
you happiness.
Well, then the final stuff
that could potentially buy you
happiness is this cruddy stuff
that you inject in your vein.
I mean, it's a final expression
of that philosophy of living.
>> Jonathan Franzen: And you're
on the hedonic treadmill.
It's like you got to-- .
>> Sam Quinones: You
never really-- happiness.
Yeah, no of course.
It makes you feel like
you've attained it
for a moment until you don't.
You haven't attained it anymore.
You've got to get back.
And the, what I've found
interesting, frankly,
was that the same guys,
the Mexican guys I
was writing about.
They never use their dope.
They would use cocaine,
they would drink.
But they never used their dope.
But they were also addicted.
They were addicted to, as, as
poor young men, leaving home,
being poor in Mexico is not just
about having not
very much money.
It's also being humiliated for
not having very much money.
They would come home with money,
and that was their narcotic.
They would, they
would accumulate.
One of the things
that they loved
to accumulate was
Levi's 501 jeans.
And because those
were the classic,
the rural gold standard for, for
men, rural menswear in Mexico
when I was there for sure.
Were Levi's 501 jeans.
They would bring them.
And, and all the
addicts would bring them,
them jeans for their dope.
Trade them dope,
jeans for the dope.
They'd take the dope,
the jeans home.
And turn, and, and give
them away like Santa Claus.
But all the, all these guys
who they'd grown up with.
All the girls want
to talk to them.
All these men would come to
them and ask for, for loans.
Well, you don't get
asked for loans.
That's a good thing.
You don't asked for loans
unless you have money.
To be, to be actually giving.
And so there's this, there's
this feeling throughout,
throughout the research that
I had that everybody was kind
of addicted to, to something.
But it was not.
They were looking for happiness.
And the truth is happiness
doesn't, this is pleasure that--
happiness doesn't
come from that.
But it's all that consumer
culture that you're referring
to I think is very, very, a
big part of our [inaudible].
>> Marie Arana: Yeah,
it's almost like it,
it actually is reminding me of,
of something that Denis wrote
that sort of vulture feeling.
Certainly that, I, it's
his journalism in Liberia.
And he, I can't remember
if this was
for Esquire magazine
or what it was for.
But he was describing this
tremendously nightmarish war.
In which the, the dogs are
looking very prosperous
and the people are starving.
And the reason why the dogs are
looking are so prosperous is
of course because they're
feeding on the corpses.
I don't know why, it's
a very, very dark image.
[Laughter]
>> Sam Quinones: You
can say that again.
>> Marie Arana: But it's a,
I, I, it suggests to me, and,
and Elliot maybe could,
could comment to this.
That it's almost
a metaphor that.
In the consumer business
it also,
you know in the business of war.
There is there are
corpses all about.
There are people dying.
This is a, a, a, crisis
that, I mean, I just,
just in the newspaper today.
A headline.
Nearly one million people,
nearly one million
Americans are not working
because they're too
sick from opioids.
Last year it was
70,000 people dead.
Year before that it
was 64,000 people dead.
More than Vietnam War.
There is this sense of
you know the, the, the,
the industry devouring almost
in a sort of warlike way.
The, these victims.
And, and there seems to
be a failure afoot of,
of responsibility in the sense.
I mean, what could we have done?
Where could we stop it?
What, what can we do now?
And a little bit of a war scene.
I would think.
Elliot.
>> Sam Quinones: Help
us out here, Elliot.
>> Elliot Ackerman: Yeah, sorry.
[Laughter] I think definitely.
I think what you
I mean, you know,
wars build their own economies.
I'm sure you've seen
this in your reporting.
And I think we have a
conventionally American
perception of war
as a war begins.
It's fought for a cause.
And then it ends, and somebody
wins, and somebody loses.
Well you know the reason we're
in our 17th year, for instance,
of fighting in Afghanistan.
Is not because we haven't
found like that perfect bit
of alchemy to, you know
defeat the Taliban.
Or whoever we've
decided our enemy is.
Is because you start
to get into a cycle
where the war just
feeds upon itself.
And why is it feeding
upon itself?
You know, one part can be you
know the internal dynamics
in an Afghanistan.
Or in Iraq and all those reasons
that we feel are
very, very far away.
I think if we, you know, if we
turned the light on ourselves.
It's also because
every war you go to,
you go to war with a construct.
You know, whether it was
the national mobilization
that existed in the Second
World War where you know
where the entire country
got behind the effort.
To you know the draft in
the Vietnam War, to today.
Where we are fighting
wars that are resourced
with an volunteer military.
And they're funded
through deficit spending.
So kind of like you
know your painkillers,
you don't feel a thing.
And it goes on and
on and on and on.
>> Jonathan Franzen: Sam, is it?
Is it your impression
that the, that these are,
you say it's about supply.
That seems to imply these
are, these are people
who if they hadn't happened
to have access to the opioids,
they would have had good,
successful, satisfying lives?
>> Sam Quinones:
It's hard to say.
You're right.
>> Jonathan Franzen:
Because that, I,
the mention of Afghanistan
puts me at, and there is this,
and as I said, there's this,
we were talking backstage.
There is an overlap
between areas of,
certainly where the opioid
crisis first made itself
particularly visible.
And Trump America.
There is a, there is a
kind of despair and a sort
of let's just burn
it all down quality.
And that's absolutely
what happens if you tear
up a country with
17 years of war.
I mean, there's like,
why not keep fighting?
>> But there's also the sense
in what you were talking about,
too, which was this, you know,
this fantasia that
we're living in.
Oh yes, we can have you know
opioid drugs and be fine.
It's also the sense
of you know, oh yeah,
we can [inaudible]
our institutions
and we'll all be
psychologically okay.
Like oh yeah, we can just
you know resource our wars
out to other people.
And not pay taxes
on them, and yeah,
that's going to work out fine.
Like it's probably,
it was a good thing
that we had a draft
in the sixties.
You know. And then everybody
you know got to a certain point.
It was like this makes no sense.
We're not doing it anymore.
And now, you just
don't [inaudible].
>> Sam Quinones: Exactly.
Oh, 100%. I've said
this, in fact, in my,
in talks that I've been giving
around the country about this.
That, that it's like we,
yeah, we just have this like.
The whole, the whole
theme really is to me,
I thought again it was drug
trafficking and that's not that.
It's, it's isolation
versus community.
You know we used to treat
pain in a variety of ways.
One person would get a
variety of approaches.
So it would be you have pain?
Chronic pain?
Well cognitive behavioral
therapy.
Diet, swimming.
Pain? Marital counseling,
you know?
You need that.
The, the marriage is pain.
So [laughter] if you-- .
Seriously, that's what
they would, that's why part
of what went into, but then
we, the pills took up all the.
We began to believe in easy
answers to complicated problems.
We began to have a-- I told
an audience the other day.
I can't remember
where it was now.
That one of the worst things
we ever did was go to war.
And then give us, give
ourselves a tax cut.
It's like we didn't really,
there's one infinitesimal part
of our population was going
ask to be going over there
and risk their lives
to fight a war.
And we were not supposed
to feel anything.
We just all want it
to be narc at times.
We all want it to
be kind of immune.
And what's more and very,
very important in all
of this I believe,
very important.
Is that we, we were not
asked to be accountable.
And not, with pain either.
We were not asked to
say, you know, when you,
you have chronic pains.
Very often it has to do
with your own personal
consumer decisions.
You don't get enough exercise.
You eat poorly, you smoke.
You drink.
You're on a variety of things.
Doctors found the patients
didn't want to hear that.
You know? And so they
just said, "You know,
doc, I want you to fix me.
You're the car mechanic.
My body's a car.
Fix me, you know?"
And we got into this
attitude of,
that I believe was
also very kind of,
just a narcotized attitude.
That we don't want
to have to deal
with our own, our own decisions.
We don't, or, or, or, or change
our way of, of, of living.
And part of it is
when we went to war.
And took, and, and were
happy to get a tax cut.
I mean, one of the lowest
points in our culture,
frankly was right there.
Really it was a very
sad day, I thought.
>> Marie Arana: Before we move
on to the last segment
of this program.
I want to thank these
extraordinary writers
who in one way or another speak
to I think Denis Johnson's work.
His sort of miraculous
ability to take so many themes
that we've talked about here.
And merge them into express--
the spectacular literature.
So thank you to Jonathan
Franzen,
thank you to Elliot Ackerman,
thank you to Sam Quinones,
before we move onto the
next part of the program.
The very tail end.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
And now, to, to tell us about
the personal, more personal side
of Denis Johnson, I want to
welcome Elizabeth Cuthrell
to come and talk about
her personal recollections
and her work in film with Denis.
Elizabeth, please.
[ Applause ]
>> Elizabeth: Good
evening everybody.
Thank you for being here.
I think I'm going to
usher in a different tone.
I hope that's okay.
I first met Denis in
1997 when my partners
and I were writing the
screenplay for Jesus' Son.
We were just starting
out in the film business.
It was our first project.
I was a huge fan of Denis' work.
I had somehow convinced
him in a phone call
to let us take a
whack at the script.
I promised him if he hated it,
we wouldn't make the movie.
And he knew I meant it.
We sent him the first draft.
He loved it, and asked to come
to New York City to meet us.
He ambled into the meting
wearing a vintage Aloha shirt.
Red cowboy boots, and Elvis
Presley glasses held together
in the middle by tape.
I was terrified and thrilled
to meet this genius whose
book we were adapting.
He seemed shy and
amused at the same time.
But what I remember
most was his generosity.
He marveled at our
adaptation and talked to us
like we were the geniuses and he
was the kid just starting out.
I asked him if he'd be willing
to play a part in the film.
And he said, "Only if I
can play Terrance Weber,
the guy with the
knife in his eye."
[Laughter] He added, "That
way, if I hate the movie,
I can use my performance
as a metaphor."
[Laughter]
So a year later, we were
on the film set together.
Denis was effusive.
He kept saying, "This is
exactly what it looked like.
This is exactly what
it felt like."
In the clip we're about
to show you, Jack Black
and Billy Crudup are working
in the ER of a hospital.
They've raided the
medicine cabinet.
And they are hammered
on a, just a cocktail
of uppers and downers.
When a guy named Terrance Weber,
played by Denis Johnson arrives.
Here's the clip.
>> I'd been working
in the emergency ward
for about three weeks, I guess.
I'd taken the job because
Michelle was pregnant
and I was trying
to be responsible.
I had nothing to do on
the overnight shift,
so I went looking for Georgie.
The orderly.
He often stole pills
from the cabinet.
>> What am I going to do about
these fucking shoes, man?
[ Music ]
>> Whatever you stole, I guess
you ate it already, right?
>> Listen to how they squish!
[ Music ]
>> Let me just check
your pockets, okay?
[ Music ]
Yeah. No. Oh.
Oh, yeah. Here's something.
[ Music ]
[ Chuckles to Himself ]
>> I hope you didn't
do this to him!
>> Me? No.
He was like this.
>> My wife did it.
>> Who brought you in?
>> Nobody.
I just walked down.
It's only three blocks.
>> Oh, we, we'd better
get you lying down.
>> Okay, I feel ready
for something like that.
>> Name.
>> Terrance Weber.
>> Your face is dark, I
can't see what you're saying.
>> Georgie?
>> What are you saying man?
I can't see.
>> What's going on, Georgie.
>> His face is dark.
>> How long ago did this happen?
>> Just a while ago.
My wife did it.
I was peeping on the lady next
door while she was bathing.
My wife waited until
I'd fell asleep
and then she decided
she's blind me.
>> Do you want me
to call the police?
>> Not unless I die.
>> Here's the situation.
We, we need to get a team here.
An entire team.
I want a good eye man.
The best eye man.
A great eye man.
I want brain surgeon.
And I want a really
good gas man.
Get me a genius.
I'm not touching that head.
We'll, we'll prep this guy.
And we'll just sit back
and just sit tight.
>> Alright.
>> Orderly.
Orderly.
>> Do you mean me?
Should I get him prepped?
>> Is this a hospital?
Is this the emergency room?
Is that the patient?
Are you the orderly?
>> Oh, hey!
[ Applause ]
>> Elizabeth Cuthrell:
Thank you.
Collaborating with
Denis on his stuff was
like stepping into
another world.
Something in me would always get
rearranged, open, challenged.
We worked on a bunch of projects
together over the years.
And were cooking up some new
ideas right up until the end.
Denis was fierce about
protecting his work.
If someone tried
to change or cut
or wrongly interpret his
writing, he would be crushed.
But he would also do what
he had to do to protect it.
At a production of one
of his plays in Chicago,
he arrived for the
final dress rehearsal
and was stunned to realize.
The director decided to use
this kind of sound machine
to weave a creepy,
weird background sound
into the production.
Denis hated it.
He spoke to the director
and producer,
but they wouldn't budge.
So as a last desperate measure,
that night after
everyone had left.
He snuck back into the theater.
Stuck the sound machine
under his jacket.
Went out and pitched
it into the river.
[ Laughter ]
Needless to say, he was locked
out of the theater from then on.
In his writing, Denis
could be merciless.
But as a friend, he
was profoundly kind.
He saw into you, but
he didn't judge you.
And when you made a bad choice,
he'd help you find
something heroic about it.
He was awake and aware,
and in my opinion hooked
up to some sacred line.
There were no layers on him.
He felt everything.
Ever infirmity, in detail,
and at the speed of light.
And that can't be easy.
But whenever I asked him how
he was, he would always say,
"I'm getting better
and better every day."
And in one of our very last
email exchanges, he wrote,
"I thought late life was
supposed to be boring.
I'm finding it more like a
trip over Niagara Falls."
He sometimes sent me emails
that read like prayers.
Here's one.
"Elizabeth, my darling sister.
The other night I was up for a
couple of hours around 2:00 AM.
I call it the night watch.
Sometimes it's the
best part of the day.
I had an insight that I
wish I could have held onto.
That everything is renewed,
replenished perpetually.
And that's what we
are, that replenishing.
I'm not the one being renewed.
I'm the renewing itself.
I'm not the one being healed.
I'm the process of healing.
That's the true me.
I felt it was truth vividly.
I was living it for
a little while.
Now it's just a concept again.
But a sweet one.
And here I pass it on to you."
Denis' openness and sensitivity
sometimes made it hard for him
to deal with the rest of us.
And especially the crazy
business side of art.
He told me when he
was out in L.A.,
trying to get work made not long
after Tree of Smoke came out.
How he got a kick out of all the
insane Hollywood bullshitters
who would forget his name.
But proudly introduce him
to each other as Dave.
[Laughter] And say,
"This is Dave.
He won the National Book Award."
These kinds of experiences
encouraged him to treat,
retreat back to Idaho or Arizona
and earn his reputation
as being reclusive.
But there was something about
the process of making plays,
screenplays and teleplays that
brought out a part of Denis
that was jazzed and
collaborative and social.
And he couldn't stay away from.
And he loved actors.
He would sometimes go into
ecstatic states listen
to them make sense of his work.
Here's part of an email he
wrote after a rehearsal.
"Elizabeth, what a
privilege to sit in a room
and watch these geniuses
at work.
Afterwards, they talk
about their dinner plans.
Head for an hour's subway ride.
Go on as if it's possible to go
after an experience like that.
I go back to the
apartment, ten minute walk.
And try not to dissolve
into the galaxies."
Lastly, I want to
talk just for a moment
about Denis' wife,
Cindy Lee Johnson.
Because there's really
no talking about Denis
without talking about Cindy.
She was his beloved.
And when he spoke about
her and their kids.
Their beautiful daughter
Lana, who's here tonight.
It was truly like he
was channeling sunlight.
Cindy took care of
everything the world demanded
of Denis so he could make art.
She was his buoy.
Denis could be impulsive
with money.
And he told me that once
Cindy took over the checkbook,
the repo man stopped
coming for his car.
[Laughter] He's always say,
"I don't know how she does it!
Does she clip coupons?
Buy everything at a fire sale?"
She dazzled him.
He never seemed to get over how
her love transformed his life.
Denis would say things like,
"When Cindy goes somewhere even
for a short while, it's
like God has died."
This is my last story.
I remember one afternoon
when Denis was giving a talk
at the News School
in New York City.
It was a rare appearance,
totally sold out,
standing room only.
It was raining, and
he got there late.
Someone appeared and rushed
him through a side door
and up onto the stage.
And he got separated from Cindy.
Another writer was
introducing him and going
on a bit long with accolades.
And I noticed Denis on
stage looking agitated.
When he finally got to the mic,
he put his hand to his forehead
to shade the bright light.
And the first thing he
said was, "Cindy Lee?
Honey? Where are you?"
And she raised her arm and
called back, "I'm here."
And he smiled his
incredible boyish smile
at the sound of her voice.
And he said, "I can't see you.
Is your seat okay?
Where are you?
Can you stand up?"
And she stood up and
said, "Yes, I'm okay.
I'm here."
And they smiled at
each other and flirted.
And he said, "Alright then."
And began to read a story.
Alright then.
It is my great honor
to introduce my precious
friend, Cindy Lee Johnson.
[ Applause ]
>> Cindy Lee Johnson:
Good evening.
Thank you, Elizabeth.
Thank you to all
the panel members.
What a wonderfully
unusual tribute.
I love it.
I also want to thank all
the ladies and gentlemen
of the Library of Congress.
For bestowing the esteemed Prize
for American Fiction
upon my beloved husband.
He so richly deserves it.
When I met Denis,
he was 39 years old.
And I immediately recognized him
as the best-looking
man in the world.
I fell in love straight away.
Only later did I realize
he was the best writer
in the world, in
my humble opinion.
But he was also this
brave pilgrim soul.
Who traveled the planet.
From searching for
pirates in the Sulu Sea.
To being the last American in
Somalia when the UN withdrew.
And consider this from a
letter he wrote in 1991.
"Dear Astronaut Selection
Officer, I am a civilian
who would like to be considered
for the one-year
astronaut training program."
That's right, he tried
to go into space!
[Laughter] He was like
a modern day Tom Sawyer.
Often he would embark
with just a fishing vest.
Filled with everything he
imagined he might need.
And the faith that he would
encounter helpers, teachers,
and guides along his path.
And he always did.
His life was a grand adventure.
He loved this world.
He loved his family.
And he loved his work.
I'm so grateful to
have his work.
His light shines
through in his writing,
and it's a gift to the world.
But oh, how I miss that man.
I will always love him.
And so to close, a slideshow.
I believe it will bear
out my best-looking man
in the world comment.
[Laughter] Also, please keep an
eye out for that fishing vest.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> Robert Casper:
Thanks so much, Cindy,
for helping us end
this celebration
on such a personal
and powerful note.
I'm Rob Casper.
I'm the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center
here at the Library.
And I would like to
call Cindy and Elizabeth
and all the participants from
tonight back out onto the stage.
So please come on out,
Cindy and Elizabeth.
Please join me in
thanking them again
for an amazing, amazing night.
[ Applause ]
Thanks to all of you for coming.
If you want to leave with a few
more books in your hand, our,
our presenters will be
signing books next door
in the Woodall Pavilion.
Before you go to get as many
books as you can though.
We ask that you please fill
out this survey that you got
when you first walked
in the door.
You can drop them
off in the back.
We hope to see you here
in just a few weeks' time
for our Poet Laureate
spring event.
Until then, have a
good night, and again,
thank you for coming out.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.